islam net is raising funds to establish
a masjid and community center in norway
every person who prays there every kid
that learns about islam every youngster
that memorizes
all of this and so much more can be on
your scale of good deeds click the link
and donate what you can
burberry
yeah but
it's fake sometimes in life things look
they don't look as they seem to be now
problem sister that's one of these
things it's fake it's not real i'm not
gonna go spend hundreds or thousands of
pounds on a damn scarf i was cold i went
to a place they had this i said just
give me a brother i'm just cold
but
with uh subway the matters are the same
what's going on
the tuna that we've been eating may have
been containing pork they found pork
protein and chicken protein and other
elements from systems with 20 samples
that they had this is in california and
that's in america if that's going on
there what the hell is going on here
subway has been identifying well tuna as
tuna but
we found out that it has these stuff in
there now as muslim that is devastating
to us let alone vegans because vegans
are very passionate about this issue as
well you know they're going to be
devastating but as muslims we have a
religious belief it's not just here of
animals being harmed in that way what
we're talking about is the hereafter
brothers and sisters this is why it's
very important for us to be careful well
what we plan on doing with me and z
shine is to uh with our new channel
dining's agenda is to visit subway and
ask them some serious questions and
actually email them because it's very
concerning and i think till then or
everything i don't think in the future
because we have a lot of options here in
the uk stay away from tuna sandwiches in
subway and actually have a big question
mark in anything else they do that is
all i have to say on the matter and i
will end with the hadith of the prophet
peace be upon him of a man who puts his
hands out and says oh lord oh lord and
the prophet said this man what he eats
is haram what he drinks is haram what he
wears is haram how does he expect this
to us to be answered very important for
us to eat haram inshallah
very important for us to eat haram
inshallah
very important for us to eat haram
inshallah you're done you're finished
and also as much as we stay away from
pork and all this kind of stuff let's
treat all other sins like zinna drinking
alcohol and other elements of theft as
as disgustingly as we look at pork till
next time assalamu alaikum
do not forget to subscribe to dining
agenda we're going to keep you updated
there because it's a food channel and
this is very important for us we will
find out very soon inshaallah what is
really going on in subway the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said the one
who builds a masjid for the sake of
allah
allah will build for him a similar house
in jannah
we want to establish an amazing masjid
for the sake of allah in the country of
norway if you donate for the sake of
allah to establish this masjid then he
subhanahu ta'ala will give you the
reward insha'allah
for every single person who becomes a
muslim in this masjid for every single
person who starts practicing the deen
from the da'wah that we give in this
masjid when they pray their salawat when
they fast in the month of ramadan when
they give in charity
every single good deed that they do you
will insha allah get the reward for that
click on the link and donate now for the
sake of allah and share the video it's
absolutely free and you will get extra
reward for everyone else to participate
in this amazing